we are assembled here somewhat
reluctantly to make the next award which
is for best achievement in directing
this year the nominated directions have
done their best to make female stars
obsolete
only one of the four even had a lady
star in his picture and that was lying
in winter the female lead in Romeo and
Juliet was a teenage newcomer the
biggest female part and Oliver sang two
songs and got choked for her trouble and
the only female in Battle of Algiers
where extras wearing veils in all army
blankets the only girlish thing about
2001 a Space Odyssey was a computer with
a noticeable list the nominees for Best
Director ah
DLO Pontecorvo the Battle of Algiers
Darko Zeffirelli for Romeo and Juliet
Anthony Harvey for lion and winter
sir Cowell Reed for oliver stanley
kubrick for 2001 a Space Odyssey
and the winner is Carol rain for Oliver
not having made a musical before you can
imagine what I owe to other people was
on a wife and of course Donnell Barton
Johnny green but so many others that
have helped me throughout it but I would
like to just make a special mention for
our producer John Wolfe number half of
all of them have just like to say how
very proud and honored I am that you
give me your Oscar to not think
here we are at the big moment best
picture of the year in 1968 was really a
vintage year for motion pictures the
Franco Zeffirelli production of Romeo
and Juliet produced by Anthony
havelock-allen and John rabe or Rachel
Rachel producer Paul Newman álava
produced by John wolf
a lion in winter Martin Cole producer
funny girl race stock producing the
winner is Oliver
I'm very privileged to be here this
evening representing the team that made
Oliver I'm deeply grateful to you all
and I particularly and very sincerely
want to thank our very great directors
Carol Reed larnouba without whom we'd
have had no film at all and all my
British and American colleagues who made
tonight possible thank you very much
but that concludes the 41st annual
Academy Awards presentation thank you
all for joining us and good night
Oh on your way home stop in and see a
movie or if you're already home go out
and see a movie
you